all right now during our town hall in
Iowa on Tuesday I spoke with President
Trump about the scandals all around
Hunter Biden and Joe Biden uh before
last night's indictment here's what he
had to say to have the Biden family and
they're making millions from barisma now
think of this from China too from China
in both cases with energy conglomerates
uh in both countries and here you have
Hunter Biden on tape admitting on Good
Morning America America he has no
experience in energy oil gas coal or
Ukraine and then Joe leveraged the
billion dollars of our money in spite of
it being Obama policy to to give them a
billion in loan guarantees uh and then
he gets the prosecutor fired Hunter was
admitted as an addict at the time no
experience continues to get paid the CFC
that's the what'sapp message I'm sitting
here next to my father and you know you
haven't fulfilled your bargain 5 days
later according to James comr $5 million
ends up in one of what comr calls their
shell accounts and do you think that Joe
Biden is compromised by these countries
based on the amount of money in business
he did with China and with Russia and
with Kazakhstan and Romania and Ukraine
do you believe that so first of all
Jamie comr and Jim Jordan are doing a
great job we'll do that real quickly
because but they are doing a great job
they are really putting it on the line
but not compromised so if you look at
the kind of money they're getting where
hunter from sitting on a
board a board he's sitting on a board
he's getting 168,000 a month they say
and he got $3 million payment and he
knows nothing about energy it's an
energy company but you take a look at
the kind of thing that's going on the
kind of money you know one of the most
egregious was because I always put
myself in a can you imagine if I did it
he never painted a painting in his life
a picture a painting never painted in
his life and they're selling paintings
for $500,000 a piece and I got wise to
it because uh the White House people
called me they want to do a p a painting
of me and they gave me the 10 great
artists you know these are really high
was Hunter on the list no Hunter wasn't
on the list just check that was the
goodness he could have been on the
list but they want and these are real
artists they make you look better than
you look even better that the only good
artists they have to make us look better
if it's a painting we have to look
better right but these a great artist
the money they get they get is a
fraction of what this guy did for Modern
Art where they throw some stuff and they
say next next and he's getting a half a
million dollars and I hear maybe it's
wrong but I hear that China bought a lot
of those paintings okay and but when I
heard the 500 I said you know that's one
that's never going to go and now people
take it like it's okay could you imagine
me doing that or my sons doing that or
no or the great of Anka Trump doing that
we like Ivanka I think we like Ivanka a
lot and no but can you imagine Eric or
Don or the concept is incredible he's
getting a half a million dollars of
painting and nobody can even check it
you know they haven't really checked it
but I hear the numbers are staggering
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else